my name is Abbie leaving and I am a
junior from Cincinnati Ohio studying
history and journalism here at Hillsdale
it is my pleasure to introduce the
speaker for this evening Andrew Klavan
is an author screenwriter and host of
the podcast the Andrew Clavin show he is
also a contributing editor to the
Manhattan Institute city journal for
which he travelled as an embedded
reporter with American troops in
Afghanistan a five-time nominee and
two-time winner of the Mystery Writers
of America's Edgar Award and a recipient
of the thumping good read award mr.
Clavin has written for numerous
publications including The Wall Street
Journal the Washington Post and The New
York Times he is an author of numerous
novels including nightmare city the
homeland er series the min the mind war
trilogy don't say a word
true crime which was made into a film by
Clint Eastwood and most recently another
Kingdom his non-fiction writings include
a memoir of his religious journey the
great good thing a secular Jew comes to
faith in Christ and a book of satire the
left use dictionary
he has written a number of screenplays
including a shock to the system which
starred Michael Caine and Gosnell the
trial of America's biggest serial killer
starring Dean Cain I have had the
privilege of learning from mr. Clavin
this past week in his course titled
covering the culture in which we have
discussed topics such as the effects of
art sex feminism and storytelling on
today's culture he is a gifted and very
wise teacher and it is an honor to have
him here at Hillsdale please join me in
welcoming mr. Andrew Clavin
[Applause]
thank you very much I really appreciate
it I so appreciate being invited to your
by Hillsdale and the Pulliam fellowship
although as I was listening to Matt
describe the characteristics of a podium
fellow I almost snuck out of the room
before you realize that I didn't fit the
bill thank you to John Miller for
inviting me as well and I have to say a
special thank you to Scott Bertram who
has kept my show on the air despite a
series of unfortunate technical events
that have belaboured us but he keeps
patching me together and I somehow get
on one of the questions oh no you know
what I also want to thank Abby and all
my students the students here are it's
an amazing place I mean I don't have to
tell you that everybody seems to know
it's an amazing place the students have
really given me this kind of wonderful
illusion that Western civilization is
not collapsing
I plan to cling to that illusion until
the moment I get back to Los Angeles I'm
gonna one of the questions I'm most
often asked is what's so damn funny why
do I keep laughing and making jokes and
writing these silly satires when it
clearly the world is going to hell in a
handbasket and we should all be very
grim and this talk tonight is really my
attempt to answer that question there's
something about human corruption that
has always struck me as comical this is
not as my wife has reminded me more than
once my most attractive personality
trait and I can even see where there
might be something a little disturbing
about it to laugh at a politician who
peddles his influence or a policeman
who's on the payroll of the mob is the
sort of behavior one expects to find
only in Hell or Chicago and it's
possible one day I'll end up in one of
the other but in my defense corruption
almost always contains an element of the
absurd it is as if the human mind
transforms itself into the age-old
parody of a dishonest philosopher who
makes the worst the worse appear the
better cause wherever human corruption
occurs there always seems to have been a
moment when the perpetrator decided that
wreaking havoc on his neighbor or his
country or his own soul or all three was
really a pretty fine idea Edgar Allen
Poe called this preposterous human
tendency toward mayhem the IMP of the
perverse as an example consider the
recent scandal in which more than 30
wealthy elites were indicted for bribing
lying and cheating to win their children
acceptance into top-notch universities
they had their perfectly healthy
offspring diagnosed with learning
disabilities so they could gain the
entry exams they photoshopped their kids
faces onto the bodies of athletes and
then paid off college athletic directors
to recommend them for acceptance the
ancient rationale for the existence of
an aristocracy was that the privileged
classes freed from the necessity of
labour and trade had the leisure to
refine their moral and aesthetic senses
and yet
these members of our American
aristocracy who should have
moral sense coming out of their ears
instead must have thoughts of themselves
here's a fine idea I will model for my
children the art of clownish dishonesty
I will train them to wallow in the
personal degradation of mindless
ambition and humiliating deception I
will ensure that their academic
achievements will be devoid of pride
their reputations will be based on lies
and their consciousness will be
blackened with shame or depraved with
rationalization and this will make me a
good parent it shouldn't strike me as
funny but it does because it is in fact
it's the oldest joke in the world it's
the joke about the guy in a tuxedo who
falls in a mud puddle or the snooty
society Diane who gets a custard pie
smack and the kisser it's funny because
they're supposed to be one thing a high
and admirable thing and instead to our
surprise they become another thing low
and ridiculous and when I say that's the
oldest joke in the world I'm not
exaggerating even a little because it's
the joke of the human condition itself
you may have heard the one about the man
and woman in the garden of paradise
everything perfect nothing to do but
make love to one another and walk with
God only one rule only one and yet
somewhere along the line the IMP of the
perverse whispered in their ears the
worse appear the better cause and the
thought occurred to them here's a fine
idea they we were created to be one
thing a high and admirable thing and
instead to our surprise we are another
low and ridiculous what makes us
uncomfortable about laughing at this is
the extent of the catastrophe there is
an echo of the fall of man in every act
of evil once corruption turns to
violence and it very often does all the
comedy goes out of it and yet the
absurdity remains whether it's a lone
gunman who slaughters people at their
prayers or an entire civilization that
emulates itself in mass murder and world
war there's always a moment when someone
indeed maybe everyone thinks to himself
this is a fine idea to do evil a human
being must first of all believe that
what he's doing is good or else that
it's a well-considered act in
for MIDI with natural law so wrote
Alexander Solzhenitsyn in The Gulag
Archipelago his Magisterial description
of Soviet Communism terrors and tortures
and prisons Sultan dissing was taking
issue with the Shakespearean notion of
evildoers who know themselves for the
bad guys they are Richard the third for
instance who declared he was determined
to prove a villain or Aaron the more who
wanted to have his soul black like his
face Sultanate sin notes that
Shakespeare's self-aware villains are
amateurs at the art of murder they
stopped short at a dozen corpses he said
because they had no ideology ideology he
writes that is what gives evildoing its
long sought justification and gives the
evildoer the necessary steadfastness and
determination that is the social theory
which helps to make his acts seem good
instead of bad in his own and others
eyes I believe even by his own logic
Sultanate skun is only half right or at
least only States half the case and he
sells my old friend Shakespeare short
he's right about this an ideology a bad
idea G is the vehicle by which the fine
idea of corruption can spread over an
entire society like a fog in the
impenetrable murk of a bad idea G the
corruption becomes all but invisible
until even the best and the brightest
can engage in the most appalling
behavior completely unawares take for
example the case of George Washington
how else but in the fog of a bad idea G
could so great and virtuous a champion
of Liberty not only hold Shadle slaves
but find their desire for freedom
incomprehensible here was the man who
with a victorious army at his command
and the support of the people at his
back refused a continental Kingdom for
love of Liberty for love of Liberty he
handed his sword and his commission over
to the civilian authorities without one
action for love of Liberty he gave
Liberty itself a local habitation and a
name the United States of America and
yet writes his biographer Ron chernow
Washington suffered from a conceptual
blind spot about slavery tending to
regard it as a fair economic exchange
until time and experience gave the great
man greater wisdom to the
of his life Washington literally could
not understand why his slaves wouldn't
work his land as diligently as he would
or why they would try to escape when he
had treated them so well he of all men
could not see that they acted for love
of Liberty he was lost in the fog of the
bad ideology of chattel slavery into
which he'd been born the same phenomenon
occurs today when otherwise true hearted
and moral women commit abortion the
child's individual and irreplaceable DNA
proves the fetus is not their body and
that therefore whether it lives or dies
is not their choice our amazing new
ability to see life within the womb
reveals the baby's obvious humanity and
capacity to suffer and yet in the fog of
a bad idea even sophisticated educated
ethically conscious women with the means
to provide the child some path to
certain survival feel justified in doing
the thing they do when the fog of
corruption is widespread and thick
enough
it's blinding effects appear in the
smallest everyday actions not long ago I
took a burs to and from a restaurant in
LA in both cars the drivers a young man
in one direction and a young woman in
the other were playing rap music at full
volume rather than ask them to turn it
off I decided to take the opportunity to
listen and by chance or Providence I
heard the same song in both directions
using the foul aspossible language the
rapper referred to women and disgusting
and dehumanizing terms and laughed and
bragged about how he had abused and
humiliated one woman through forced sex
and violence it occurred to me as I rode
along that these uber drivers were
probably very nice young people maybe
they remembered to call their mothers on
Sunday maybe their friends could count
on them in times of trouble and so on
and yet not only that they seemed to
feel no compunction about grooving to
violent pornography while on the job
they seemed to think the elderly
gentleman in the backseat
the customer who would determine the
degrees of their star ratings and the
size of their tips might also enjoy a
bit of musical rape and human
degradation or at least finding it no
cause to complain until I arrived at my
destinations I was fully immersed in an
atmosphere of moral madness the
existence of this atmosphere changes our
sense
individual responsibility despite the
fact he participated in the evil of
chattel slavery we honor George
Washington is a great man and rightly so
we may be appalled by the act of
abortion but were shocked if even an
anti-abortion Crusader suggests that the
decent women who kill their unborn
babies should be in prison and if I had
dragged one of my uber drivers out from
behind the wheel and given him or her a
stern talking-to about what a decent
song lyric sounds like I would have
earned the description of me that
appeared recently in the magazine Vanity
Fair when they called me an old crank
truer words to live in a state of moral
madness is to live in a kind of
ignorance ignorance in the Platonic
Aristotelian sense is when Aristotle
says every wicked person acts in
ignorance of the things he ought to do
and avoid in this widespread atmosphere
of ethical insanity
even those who dissent often can no
longer fully experience the absurdity
and horror of what's happening around
them it wasn't villains or gangsters who
called for the crucifixion of Christ it
was the good people the religious
leaders the guardians of morality and
the decent ordinary men and women on the
street you and me even those who had
recognized Jesus as the Messiah days
before at best stood by and watched as
the wretched thing was done we have it
on good authority that they knew not
what they did but just how deep does
this ignorance go how complete isn't the
slave holder or the aborting mother
where the youngster tapping his tones to
toes to tunes of rape and savagery are
they really wholly unaware that they are
acting wrongly that they have at least
temporarily lost their moral Minds to be
sure a person can become so depraved his
conscience dies but can everyone
everywhere forever sin in blissful
ignorance I don't believe they can
that's not what the evidence suggests
this is what I meant when I said that
Sultanate sans statement is only half
true by his own logic he says that to do
evil a human being must first of all
believe that what he's doing is good but
this implies that humans instinctively
know there are such things as good and
evil and have an inborn sense of what it
takes to create
a moral justification that transforms
one into the other after all no one ever
had to devise an ideology to justify
kindness or charity or love this is the
place where I should point out that
science confirms to some degree that
we're inherently moral beings
experiments at the Yale infant cognition
Center show that even six-month-old
babies prefer helpful actions to
hindering actions were born with a moral
sense or at least developed one very
early on but to be honest and as I'll
explain later
and not very impressed with these
experiments it may be a sort of
blasphemy to say this in the 21st
century but I am virtually certain that
Jesus Aristotle and Shakespeare had a
more accurate and holistic mental image
of humanity than our current
psychologists so let's go back to
Shakespeare assaults Anacin points out
many of his villains don't take the
trouble to convince themselves they're
doing good they act in the words of st.
Augustine with no inducement to evil but
evil itself
some like Aaron the moor and Iago are
irredeemably beyond remorse but many of
the bars most prolific murderers are
brought low by a moral force that seems
to come from both within them and
without Richard the third may be
determined to prove a villain but the
ghosts of his victims returned to him on
Bosworth Field and demand that he
remember his atrocities despair and die
Lady Macbeth prays to the spirits to
fill her heart with the diarist cruelty
but she then executes herself because
she can't watch the visionary blood off
her hands perhaps most profoundly
Macbeth himself having slaughtered his
way to the throne of Scotland comes to
understand that in doing so he is
stepped out of the meaning of life into
a tale told by an idiot full of sound
and fury signifying nothing
in other words some of Shakespeare's
worst villains not only fall afoul of
conscience but conscience is conceived
of as an organ of perception that sees a
moral reality that actually exists if
only in the interplay between man's mind
and the mysterious world as it is to put
that more simply Shakespeare's villains
feel guilty because they're guilty they
know right from wrong because there is
right and wrong and mankind's is created
in such a way that we can tell the
difference and we can't stop
knowing even when our fallen humanity is
moved to do evil I believe the evidence
for the truth of shakespeare's vision is
found not just on stage but everywhere
around us again and again we see
unmistakable signs that people who do
evil even after convincing themselves
that evil is good are tormented by the
two-headed fury of conscience and moral
reality even in a world gone mad where
everyone around them is convinced that
the worse is the better cause they know
the truth and suffer from the knowledge
look at the way they behave people who
defend evil ideologies justify
themselves with constant expectations of
catastrophe as if we were in an endless
state of war like emergency that
required the suspension of moral order
people who defend idle uh evil
ideologies stifle dissent as if even a
mention of their error will force them
to face the truth of it and they
reliably stumble from smaller sins into
greater and greater atrocities as if
they hope to escape to some level of
complete depravity at which their
wickedness will finally seem sanctified
to them read the diaries of the American
slaveholders they were obsessively
afraid that their slaves would rise up
and murder them in their beds
the phrase murdered in our beds is
almost a constant refrain from them does
that suggest a quiet conscience or
return to the Soviets and their gulags
if they were fully convinced that the
Communist Party was the source of all
goodness why were they so desperate to
crush any disagreement why did they see
dissent everywhere even when there was
none they imprisoned tortured and
executed people not just for the
slightest aberration from communist
ideology but for the possibility that
aberration might one day occur do men
who are certain of their moral position
behave that way or is it only those
whose sense of virtue depends on a
shared delusion so fragile that even the
possibility of clarity will shatter it
finally consider a vote in the American
Senate just last February a bill that
would have strengthened the penalties
for denying care to babies born alive
after an attempted abortion was scuttled
by 44 senators who support abortion less
than a quarter century after such
supporters told us abortion should be
safe legal and rare they're activists
are encouraging women to shout
there are abortions with pride and their
lawmakers cast votes that deny
protections to fully born babies
if a baby fully born is not a human
being with a right to life
who the hell is but of course if you
have taken a step down the road to evil
you're forced to run farther and farther
down that road
lest you stop and turn and see yourself
as you are whether they act with no
inducement to evil but evil itself or
justify their acts with ideology those
who do wrong feel guilty because they
are guilty and they act that way they
see catastrophe looming everywhere they
stifle dissent they escape from smaller
sins into greater and greater atrocities
they've distorted the moral universe and
their own souls they are living in a
world gone mad Christians believe that
this madness is to some degree intrinsic
to our situation that could almost serve
as a definition of original sin if
nothing else that theory acts as a
corrective to nostalgia the temptation
to believe that life was far better and
more moral in the good old days
recently I was discussing a platonic
dialogue with my son Spencer a brilliant
classical scholar trained at Yale in
Oxford reflecting on the convulsions of
outrage and dialectical savagery on
social media I told Spencer I yearned
for that more civilized world of ancient
Athens where a great philosopher like
Socrates could spend his days discussing
ideas with his pals in the Agora
after a brief embarrassed silence my son
said quietly dad
they killed Socrates so much for the
good old days indeed before these times
of rampant abortion and rap music there
were days when people were set on by
police dogs and lynch mobs for the crime
of having brown skin there were
Holocaust and slavery and war there
always are the fog of insanity thins and
gathers hangs offshore and comes rolling
in but there is always moral madness
somewhere and there is always someone
who will call it justice still as the
great philosopher Gandalf the wizard
told Frodo we have to decide what to do
with the time that has given us
have to determine how to behave when our
era when our corner of the world goes
insane to reach as I have the age of
Gandalf is to see them is to see the
world as from a height you lose touch
with life on the ground a little but you
gain perspective I look around at the
United States and I see a nation full of
wonders longer life in better health
than ever before running water
everywhere plentiful and inexpensive
food all information literature and art
available at the touch of a pocket-sized
phone most of the crises we face are
crises of the imagination if when
reading the news you edit out all the
stories about the disasters some gloomy
experts think might happen you'll be
amazed at just how terrific things are
here to paraphrase the immortal lyrics
of Johnny Mercer in the only lousy song
he ever wrote for Americans everything
truly is tickety-boo I attribute this
astounding liberation from humankind's
long history of poverty plague and
violence to three developments science
capitalism and liberalism by which last
I mean the commitment to self-government
and individual human rights it's my
personal theory that these three
innovations spring from one idea the
idea that all creation is made to work
in freedom without intrusive overseers
that's the thought that links Isaac
Newton to Adam Smith to the American
Founding Fathers science capitalism and
liberalism all assumed that the proper
machinery is in place and does not need
to be micromanaged God does not need to
tinker with the Stars he made them to do
the starry stuff they do governments
don't need to control the economy if we
trade with each other under a few
reasonable rules of fairness our
ambition and creativity will cause
everyone to rise and thrive and
individuals don't require monarchs to
dictate their actions thoughts and
speech we've been given the moral
wherewithal to run our own homes
communities and countries ourselves in
this three and one Trinity of ideas we
have become uniquely blessed but in
defense of those blessings it's
worthwhile to note the patches of fog of
bad ideology that seemed to be gathering
in the intellectual centers where the
culture of the future is often made to
remind you the three symptoms I look for
are inordinate fear of catastrophe the
silencing of dissent and the steady
progress from moral error to atrocity I
find these symptoms beginning to appear
to various degrees of severity in elite
thinking about the economy race and sex
in the realm of the economy capitalism
and improved property rights have cut
extreme poverty in half worldwide over
the last 30 years and in America the
poor now live at the level of the middle
class of the 1980s yet a presidential
candidate who praised the mass murdering
communists of Cuba and unapologetically
honeymooned in the slave state of the
Soviet Union preaches socialism to a
nodding press and cheering crowds of
young people in the matter of race
relations surely there is one and only
one correct approach to love your
neighbor who's made in God's image and
to judge each person by the content of
his character rather than the color of
his skin yet after my father's
generation fought to end the wickedness
of segregation and Jim Crow I see my
children's generation attending
universities with segregated dorms where
they have taught the viciously racist
philosophy of intersectionality as if it
were the cure to bigotry rather than a
new strain of the old disease as for
human sexuality is always a disordered
business where the most urgent desires
of our material bodies and the deepest
longings of our fallen souls can join
but that there is such a thing as human
sexuality that it is centered on the
differences between the two sexes male
and female
that those differences are written into
our very cells and are among the chief
joys and consolations of experience and
indeed are the very archetype and
inspiration of all earthly love and
creation these are human universals
known from the jungle up and essential
to the formation of every single science
aasaiya tea that has ever existed on
earth the idea that these yin-yang
bedrock facts of life are merely
cultural constructs and can therefore be
completely erased by wishing very hard
and dressing in one another's clothes
is simple lunacy in each of these cases
I see exaggerated fear of catastrophe in
the form of climate panic overblown
anxiety about fascism and white
supremacism and the anguished hysterical
cowering from debate in so called safe
spaces I see the silencing of dissent
where voices of fact and logic science
and experience are punished in the
workplace edited out of search engines
de platformed from social media and
barred from campus or met with heckling
and violence and I see the progress from
error toward atrocity from government
interference and cronyism in the economy
to the certain economic ruin of
socialism from supposedly corrective
racial preferences to resurrected
segregation and the bigotry of
intersectionality and from the
disparagement of femininity and
motherhood to infanticide and the sexual
butchery of children in the name of
gender reassignment like the good ideas
that have brought us so far these bad
ideas to my mind are all one idea it is
the idea that man is matter and that
therefore the moral world can only be a
fictional creation of his brain which
can be changed by changing the stories
he's told and is allowed to tell I
mentioned earlier that I don't entirely
trust the modern psychological studies
of human morality detailed in books by
psychologists like Jonathan Haight Paul
bloom and Steven Pinker the reason is
this they're based on the idea that
human morality is entirely a creation of
evolution and nothing more consider the
logic that of that for a minute
surely the human sense of sight evolved
to see light because in reality there is
a phenomenon that can be seen as light
the sense of hearing evolved because in
reality there are such phenomena that
can be apprehended as sound likewise the
human sense of morality evolved does it
then follow that morality is entirely
our creation entirely subject to our
changing opinions our light and sound
our creations no now the human
experience of things that are there so
it is with morality conscience is our
human sense of a truth about the
universe the psychologists should have
read their Shakespeare
let me finish up with an example of how
this faulty logic can lead into bad feed
into bad ideology in studies of evolved
morality psychologists tell their
subjects little stories and ask them to
make moral judgments about them in one
of these stories a loving brother and
sister commit an act of incest they have
sex they're careful the sister doesn't
get doesn't get pregnant they never
repeat the act and their relationship
continues as before people hear this
story and instinctively sense that
incest is wrong but they can't explain
why it's wrong in this particular case
from this some psychologists conclude
that the incest taboo is an outmoded
evolutionary remnant from the days when
the resulting dangerous pregnancies
could not be prevented but the story
itself is based on the false premise
that human beings are mere physical
objects that the spiritual relationship
between brother and sister has no real
being no inherent nature and that
therefore brother and sister can have
sex without violating the core truth of
that relationship in fact in the story
they have sex without changing their
relationship at all which has never
happened to anyone ever no matter who
they were since the world began what the
psychologists have really discovered is
that the human moral sense evolved to
perceive reality not stupid stories that
falsely describe reality in fact the
subjects instinctively understand the
moral universe better than the clever
shrinks who wrote the stories if you've
ever wondered why intellectuals seem so
incredibly stupid sometimes that's why
now carry this logic over to a more
pressing issue like abortion the moral
philosopher Judith Jarvis Thompson wrote
a famous paper called the defense of
abortion which includes this now very
popular argument Thompson describes a
situation in which you wake up and find
yourself next to a famous violinist the
violinist has a fatal kidney condition
and your kidneys are now hooked up to
his to keep him alive in nine months the
violinist will recover and then you'll
be free Thompson argues that you have
the right to unhook yourself from the
violinist because he should not be
allowed to force you to use your body
for his survival therefore you have the
right to have an abortion on the same
grounds now Thompson is a famous moral
philosopher and I'm just a barefoot
of tales but that's nuts for one thing
it sounds like Thompson missed the day
and health class when they explained
that you don't just wake up one day and
find yourself pregnant that's not how
that works but more importantly she
conceives of a world in which there's no
such thing as motherhood in which it's
not a unique spiritual relationship with
a unique set of moral responsibilities
she conceives of the womb is something
like a dialysis machine rather than as a
material part of a whole human who
exists in a moral universe with which
her humanity is interwoven and to which
it is bound the same materialist illogic
applies to socialism which seeks to
solve all human ills with money and thus
Rob's the individual of his work his
ambition and his charity of which money
is only a symbol the same illogic
applies to intersectionality which
ignores the individual's wisdom
accomplishments and abilities in order
to apportion privileges according to the
same racialist principles held by bigots
and the same logic applies to the
attempts to override the yin-yang
complementarity of women and men in the
name of equality as if by changing a
pronoun or even reshaping a body you
could change the nature of the human
person that pronoun or body only
represents the battle for a better world
is ultimately not a battle against
individuals but against bad ideas like
these that Express the absurdly fallen
human heart and the IMP of the perverse
we don't have to tear down George
Washington's statue statue to condemn
chattel slavery we don't have to
imprison women to renounce the killing
of babies we don't have to defend
immoral capitalists to defend capitalism
itself we wrestle not against flesh and
blood says st. Paul but against
principalities against powers against
the rulers of the darkness of this world
against spiritual wickedness in high
places we are in a war of ideas in which
we must defend the idea of the human
soul and the moral world in which it has
its being and its rights to life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness we need to
mount this defense with logic with
science with patience with you
and with courage we need to do it yes
even if they ban us from Twitter and
Facebook we need to do it even when they
riot on campus at our speeches we need
to do it even if our professor marks us
down and our boss sends us to HR and our
sponsor drops our show and god prevent
it should ever come to this but if it
lasts the truth itself is outlawed than
outlaws we must become outlaws like
Socrates and Jesus and the believers who
face the Roman lions and the Patriots
who face the British guns I don't mean
to be melodramatic but we have to at
least embrace the principle that telling
the truth about the human condition is
worth great sacrifice so we'll be ready
to face the lesser sacrifices that even
here even now the truth sometimes
demands we have to be ready to make
those sacrifices for truth because the
wages of Lies are corruption slavery and
death this country has been so free so
safe so powerful so long that it's easy
to forget how quickly freedom can be
lost in the fog of bad ideas wandering
in that fog the world goes mad and in a
world gone mad we cannot be silent thank
you thank you very much
Thank You mr. Clavin we now have time
for a few questions please raise your
hand and wait for a microphone to be
brought to you thank you sir Oh what
would you have us do what would you what
I have you do well I think everywhere
everywhere speech is under threat you
have to speak up and fight back I mean
that's that is the main thing and
everybody has the power to do that
because everybody has the power to speak
you have the power to speak at dinner
tables you have the power to speak in
your public squares we have the power to
speak everywhere and if you look around
it is intolerable I mean this is this is
the first wave of the way you lose a
country it's intolerable how people
suffer for the things they say that are
true for the things they say that they
shouldn't have said
even for gaffes they make an anger it is
absolutely absurd that people should
lose their jobs over comments they made
10 years ago or or unfortunate lapses
even of politeness and so what I would
have everybody do I mean every one of us
carries a piece of the culture in our
hands you know the culture doesn't just
belong to Hollywood it doesn't just
belong to the news business or the
Academy it belongs to everybody so the
way you treat each other is the way you
treat people and it's what you're ready
to say and I just believe that with
ultimate politeness with ultimate
kindness with ultimate compassion for
people who are truly suffering you
should speak the truth
hi thank you so much for coming so my
question is do you think that Young
Conservatives better serve society by
going to big liberal universities and
speaking out about our values to our
peers or by coming to conservative or
religious schools and focusing on
receiving a good education you know I
think I think that since no it's it's a
great question because I mean we have
this question that the Hollywood version
of this question is do I pretend to be
something I'm not so I can worm my way
into Hollywood or do I speak out boldly
and get blacklisted you know I mean it's
the same thing do you go where into
enemy territory or do you stay among
friends
but in the in this case of this
particular question you're talking about
a time of preparation you're talking
about a time before your your career
begins and to have the education that
you have in a place like this to know
why you think the things you think is
just invaluable I around I speak to
colleges a lot and I'm just shocked
I mean I've considered almost a form of
child abuse I'm just shocked at how
young people have been stripped of their
of their of the basic knowledge of why
we do the things we do you know it's not
like you can't have revolution and
change and evolution it's that you ought
to know you know the the patterns of
your traditions and why they're there
before moving on to the next stage I
would I would I wish I mean I went to
the University of California at Berkeley
so I know what I'm talking about I wish
I had come to a place like this I wish I
had come out knowing why I thought the
things I thought and I did I didn't have
to build the wheel from the ground up
you know that's my my dancer you know my
wife tells me that it's my mission in
life to alienate every single human
being alive and that's why I hope some
I've added some of you too
[Laughter]
thank you so much for coming my question
is how do we start a dialogue and a
conversation in defense of truth when we
don't have a shared vocabulary in other
words you know in your speech you
reference for example Shakespeare's
Richard the third platonic dialogues
Socrates and thankfully we're at a place
where most of us understand those
references but when we have a culture
that's lost sight of the Western
tradition how do we begin to defend
ideas of Liberty that are inherently
based on that tradition right it's you
it's not just a shared vocabulary shared
premises sometimes I think a lot of the
arguments that are taking place in
America today is because we don't even
share basic premises you know one of the
kind of tricks that they have that the
right has that I don't particularly like
is when they send us out to speak what
they really want is they want us to say
something that gets the left upset and
then some lefty student will yell at you
and you'll put him down and then they'll
put you on YouTube with that thing that
says Andrew Clavin destroys a left is
always pleasant
big capital letters and I'm a terrible
failure at doing this because first of
all I actually like people and I have a
hard time destroying anybody and I think
what but the funny thing is is I don't
get yelled at a lot I mean I say the
things that I you've just heard me say
in places where if you say them they
will beat you to death and nobody does
and the reason is I try to start with a
premise that we can all get behind so I
frequently start by saying all I want is
for you to be free I don't care what you
do I don't care if you take drugs I
don't care who you sleep with that's
none of my business
I'm older and wiser than you so I can
tell you that some of the things you do
we're going to ruin your life but still
they're not going to ruin my life
so you know be be at peace starting with
that premise there is nobody beneath the
age of 20 you're in that age who doesn't
want to be free they all want to be free
and so they stop and they start to
listen and then I can explain why from
the ground up the founding fathers
thought this is the best way to make you
free and and then you suddenly have a
shared premise to talk with and that
really works for me I have been heckled
a couple of times but I've never been
attacked and I've never nobody swung at
me or anything like that and so I think
that that's what you have to do you have
to find the place the basic place where
you agree and then start to build up
your argument from there
[Laughter]
okay my question is your uber rides if
you sat through it you condone it if you
hear young people using the type of
language that you can hear and you find
it offensive I believe we as seasoned
citizens have the right to say to them
you are disturbing me what would you
remark be I think I completely agree
with you the only thing about it is as I
almost always I don't like to listen to
music and uber so I almost always get in
and say could you turn that off but I
thought this was an educational
experience because I don't listen to rap
music and I hear people grouse about it
but I wanted to hear what was in it and
I thought it was worth doing
I you can bet I'll say something next
time but I didn't want to speak in
ignorance so I didn't want to just go
off I went home and looked up the lyrics
to make sure I was hearing the right
thing you know you know and I and I
think that to just go off to just go off
on people is ineffective I guess is what
I would say to you that I want next time
I'll know what I want to say and I'll do
it but I thought this time I was a
learning experience for me it took me it
yeah it took me two times to actually
believe I was hearing what I heard and
then and then as I said I I thought to
myself that I'm just an old you know I
gotta look it up and I looked it up and
I thought no that's actually what he was
saying you know and and it was it was
really it took me a while I have to
think about it I have to think it
through you know I thought like these
were obviously nice kids they were
making a living probably in Hollywood
every driver is trying to be an actor
you know and and I thought you know
pumping something that like that into
your brain I mean you might as well just
have a nail then you're shoving it nail
in your ear it's a terrible thing to do
to yourself you know but it I'm a slow
thinker and it took me a while to kind
of meditate on it and work with my way
through it and I you know I basically
agree with you though you know I would
not sit and listen to that again
so long walk shoulda brought a horse
yeah you need your tennis shoes rather
than the heel sweetie I was when to ask
thank you for a fabulous presentation I
wanted to ask you about Jordan Peterson
who seems to be catching young catching
fire with a lot of younger people who
were brought up in in the leftist a
khadeem and are thirsty for truth and
he's defending Western civilization now
he's doing it from a more humanist
perspective from what I understand but I
just wanted to get your opinion on what
he's been saying and so yeah well III
like I like him I like Jordan and I read
his book and thought it had a lot of
smart wise advice in it
Michael Knowles and I might my colleague
at the Daily wire we have a cruel sport
that we play with them
whenever we see Jordan we ask him write
up if he believes in God and I it's like
shooting at a man's feet to watch him
dance you know it and the problem he has
which I really respect of all I respect
anybody I'd rather hear somebody
honestly tell me what he thinks but you
know he goes into these the last time I
asked him seriously he ended up talking
about thathe many I Diamond and I was
like you know I'm sorry it's hilarious
but but anyway the thing is Jordan
Jordan is a union and and young believe
that we don't know whether God is an
outward manifestation or whether he is
simply what happens when the human
consciousness connects with everything
so basically his God is kind of a
metaphor and I think it's a weak link in
Jordan's thinking and whenever he's
asked about it he refuses to answer and
he says I don't want to be pinned down I
don't want to be put in a binary box
where I have to say yes or no and I
disagree with that I think that every
truth is a binary box if the earth is
round it's not flat you know if there's
a god then there is not not a god you
know and I think it I think it is a flaw
in his thinking and I think he sometimes
covers it up with verbiage however
however he gives good advice
I know many people who have been led to
God by listening to Jordan and I think
he's doing the good work you know that
we all do he's
not responsible to me for what he
believes that's just my my personal take
on it you know but basically I think
he's doing good work you know thank you
for your comments tonight um in your
podcast you've talked about you think a
great spiritual or religious awakening
may be coming and I wanted to see if you
could elaborate on that and also talk
about how that that might happen when
the numbers of religious people in this
country seem to be going down yeah
especially among young people you know
now nuns know religion seems to be
increasing a lot you know first of all I
think that that's true well we're losing
our religion I consider that I'm
optimistic about this and I'll explain
why in a minute I considered it a
calling of the herd I think the people
who are not were falling away are not
people they're not believers
they're practicers they're people who
maybe their parents told them to go
nobody ever explained to him I mean I I
left I became an agnostic and then an
atheist because you know my parents sent
me to Hebrew school but they didn't
believe in God and I thought listen make
any sense you know this makes absolutely
no sense at all I think a lot of kids
are growing up in that environment I am
a great believer that ideas collapse
when they make no sense that they follow
that people will hold on to ideas as
they play themselves out to their
furthest extent and then they'll say oh
that makes no sense the principles of
the last 40 years or so which have been
called post-modernism or
deconstructionism are the idea that
there is no essential truth that
everything is relative to your
perception that man's mind everything
takes place in man's but that doesn't
make any sense
I mean you know I won't go on forever
about it but it's simply an idea you
know whenever somebody tells me there's
no truth I always asked was that true
and and I think and I think that kids
are I know this I know this because I
hang out with sometimes you know my son
goes to very elite universities I know
some of these kids and and they're
starting to say this doesn't make any
sense it just doesn't hold water and
they're starting to meet together and
talk about the Gospels they're trying to
reinvent the Gospels for a new age which
I don't think is a bad thing some people
you know I don't think the Gospels were
meant to freeze us into first century
morality that's not the way they read to
me at all but I do think they're meant
to freeze us into a moral world that is
not up to us and not responsible to us
and I see it happening alright young
people you know I live in LA there's a
church there for young people where they
play rock music and all this stuff I've
attended it several times when you walk
toward it I mean there are people
pouring in it's held in this huge
auditorium it is packed and everybody
there I mean I'm older than like three
people put together there you know I
mean it is it is a young young crowd
it's happening now and the way I expect
it to happen is I expect it to happen at
the intellectual level
many of our revivals in this country
have happened at the street level
they've happened in tents they've
happened on street corners I think
what's going to happen now is the
thinkers are going to say you know I
cannot make sense of this anymore
I'm going to go a different way and I
think a generation is coming up where
that's going to happen at the Academy
level and once it happens at the Academy
level the atheists are done because you
cannot win that argument you simply
cannot win the argument I mean I don't
mean to be rude to anyone who's not a
believer I'm just telling you like it
does I I was an atheist and an agnostic
for most of my life I was baptized at
the age of 49 I have been down every
wrong road as it's possible to go down
and it's only it's only logic that led
me where I was to where I finally ended
up it's only reason that did it you know
as I always say Jesus didn't reach down
into the gutter and pull me up when I
was lying there drunk not that I can
remember but but it was simple it was
simple logic and I do believe I really
do have faith that at some point bad
ideas collapse and they either collapsed
as they don't work or they collapse
because somebody says
you know a doesn't equal a anymore and I
think that that's what's happened I
think we are moving away from
post-modernism at the level of these
young people here and at the level of
young people in in all kinds of at all
kinds of levels of of universities we'll
see you know yeah and ER I just wanted
to ask you about the time you spent with
the military as an embedded reporter I'm
currently serving and the national guard
I'm from Indiana and I wondered what you
thought about and I don't I don't know
what your exposure to the UCMJ and
speaking against the secular culture in
the military and the repercussions
potentially for that are and maybe how
to speak truth in that environment maybe
some tips for somebody in that yeah I
mean when I was there I went to a chapel
there were two guys there you know so I
I was I was pretty surprised I didn't
know the cultures of the people I was
with obviously and I'm not sure maybe
many of them believe but just didn't
like going to that particular Chapel or
whatever you know the the people the
reason I went to Afghanistan was because
I was working in the movie business and
I was writing screenplays and Hollywood
started to make these movies against the
war wars on terror and I felt I didn't
feel it was wrong to oppose the war if
that was your opinion that was fine but
I felt it was very wrong to make movies
propaganda instruments against the war
while our soldiers were in harm's way
that didn't happen in Vietnam that you
know didn't happen in World War two the
first time that ever happened where they
were making gigantic propaganda tools
for the enemy while our guys were in the
field and so I started to write about
that this is how I entered my Hollywood
career I started to write about that and
and I wanted to write with some
authority so I managed to wangle my way
into an embed for a few days in
in Afghanistan and I found the soldiers
incredibly decent human beings I mean I
found that it to be a culture of true
courage and self what's the word I'm
looking for you know that they were they
didn't take themselves seriously but
they took their work seriously and they
were really quite magnificent people I
found what they believed in terms of
spirituality I just don't know and what
I'm not really clear to be honest with
you what the policy of the military is
are they shutting people up are they
forcing people not to to speak faith and
to worship I mean I hear that on
right-wing venues all the time but I
find it hard to believe you know I don't
think I can hear you without the mic I'm
sorry all right so as far as military
policy and such there are mandated
classes such as the sharp program which
is a more or less a forced program to
tell people not to rate people I suppose
and it's it's really just a lot of
secular humanist feminist propaganda
more or less and a lot of finger wagging
and down speaking to military members
assuming that people are just
essentially cattle in a sense and it's
it's very frightening when you see
things happen to people that kind of
stand up to that culture more or less
just disappear and it I blanking on the
name of the guy at the moment I had
drilled us last weekend worked about 55
hours in three days and have just been
going nonstop but I can't get out of
fights
I work in claims in the insurance
dealing with angry contractors and
things of that nature but sorry I'm
going off on a tangent there
anyways the the culture in the military
is just one that is in my opinion
secular humanist experiment and it is a
forced culture that forces you to
embrace that culture and kowtow to it
and so yeah speaking truth there is is
rather difficult and I wondered if you
had any tips on that
well yeah I mean I get this question all
the time the question is always how do I
speak truth to my professor how do I
speak and really that's only half the
question the question is really how do I
speak truth to my professor without
suffering the consequences and the fact
is you can't I mean we are under we're
under fire from the left they their
ideas don't make sense and so their only
thing they can do is silence us
that's the that's the only weapon they
have knock us off Twitter call us
fascists call you know they I mean you
know I work with ben shapiro they call
him a nazi you know i keep saying you
know you oughta wear the yarmulke with
the swastika on it you know you know i
mean they'll do they'll do anything
anything to silence us and that means
you got to pay the price I mean I paid
the price of my Hollywood career that
that's that's millions of dollars and I
never lost a night's sleep over it
because other people were getting shot
and I thought it was worth saying what I
had to say I don't I tell this the young
people all the time everything cost
something and there's no shame in
counting the cost but there is a shame
and selling something priceless because
you're afraid you know that that's that
is a shame it's a shame to lose your
ability to speak the truth because
you're afraid you're gonna take a hit
you know I think that you pick your
battles you choose what you're willing
to pay but you cannot surrender this you
can't because they really want the whole
culture I mean it is just amazing they
don't want anybody working making movies
who disagrees with them they don't want
anybody writing books who disagrees with
them I I got my latest book another
Kingdom I'll tell you I wrote books for
young adults for a Christian publisher
and I told them I'm not going to preach
to anybody but what I'll do is I'll make
that you
Khristian I'll make the hero you know
that's it he'll just be a Christian and
he'll do what Christians do and it'll be
the hero and that's the only you know
preaching that'll be involved and so I
wrote these books they were sold very
well in America called the homeland er
series and I got a big sale for them in
England and after a while they appeared
on my the manuscript appeared on my desk
and it was edited and that doesn't
happen usually the foreign people don't
edit your manuscript so I said I called
up my agent I said what's this and they
said well they want you to cut out all
the references to the Bible no kidding I
mean in there and there was nothing you
know there was just stuff like instead
of saying you know I know not to steal
he would say well I know the Ten
Commandments I know not to steal it
wasn't like you know again it wasn't
preaching it was just he was living in
that biblical world and I said you know
they wouldn't say that to a Muslim they
probably wouldn't say it to a Jew you
know I'm not gonna do it five times they
came back to me with a manuscript five
different times and they told me if you
do not do this the biggest bookstore in
England water stones will not carry the
book and I wouldn't do it and they did
not carry the book they cut their order
in half you know the book never did well
in England that's bad you know I gots a
big hit but what was what it was really
the alternative I mean really what was
the alternative
I'll cut stuff out of a book if it's
gonna offend a certain audience you know
I'm not against that but how could you
possibly and nobody could understand why
I kept saying over and over again you
can't ask me to do this you know and
they thought I was nuts that's the world
we're going to be living in soon that's
in England where things are much further
advanced than they are here but that'll
happen here too
you know books have lost contracts
because they said something about Islam
or about Mohammed that Islamists didn't
like you know I think that if we're not
willing to take some hits that's what it
they win that's all there is do it if
we're if we are not willing to pay some
price for the truth they win we have
time for one more question mr. Clavin
thank you for speaking this evening I'd
like you to clarify
by one point specifically what is the
angle of these conversations to have
with people of opposite views obviously
people generally don't change their
views after one conversation so what
should be the end goal of them well you
know I think that the end goal is first
of all to convince them I mean one of
the the biggest you know I was a liberal
I grew up in a liberal family either one
you know one thing liberals know is they
don't know much but they know that
conservatives are bad people and you
know that's why you know my father
thought every Republican was in Nazi you
know he did you know he thought he
thought of a Republican was elected dog
catcher like we were one step away from
the gas chambers you know that was like
you know that was his that was his
feeling about Republicans and
conservatives and what happened to me is
that the Berlin Wall came down and I
thought that evil Reagan that idiot that
war monger that fool that movie actor
was right about everything
how did that happen you know so I
started to look I started to approach
right-wing ideas and I thought well
right away the one thing I can see is
they're not Nazis you know so let's find
out a little more so if you only get
that far if you only get that far that's
a big victory once they understand that
no you know you you want them to be free
you're not trying to hurt anybody you
don't hate people with different colors
skin which is absurd you know has never
been a conservative principle that I
didn't know in America you know you've
made a big dent that's a big thing to do
because it starts them thinking and
means that they can start to listen and
then who knows how long it'll take you
know I I was very pro-abortion to my
youth got in a all might argument with a
very dear friend of mine probably my
oldest friend devout Catholic and I went
to bed that night and I thought I lost
that argument I lost that argument it
took me 20 years to change my mind but
it haunted me man because I don't lose
arguments you know so I thought like if
I lost that argument there's got to be a
reason and I looked for reasons and
couldn't find one I thought maybe I was
wrong you know I know it happened once
before it was
so so so you know these your plant seeds
you know and I certainly the the see
that you're not evil you're not racist
you're not a Nazi all that stuff that
they fill their heads with so they won't
listen to you
is really important I think that just
that it's a victory yeah thank you
thanks very much
[Applause]